así es Pues ese es el primer gran
encuentro de cuartos aquí en este
mundial Brasil contra Croacia Brasil que
parte como la gran favorita no solamente
de este partido sino como la favorita
para levantar la copa aquí en
Qatar en un partido que va a ser
bastante complicado En todo caso se
espera porque por ahora Brasil no ha
tenido ningún rival digamos que por
ahora pueda ponerle el pie encima Ya
vimos ese baile en goles y en
celebraciones sé que tuvieron ante Corea
del Sur Pero bueno Croacia es otra cosa
es un equipo que tiene muchísima
resiliencia un equipo que tiene una
mentalidad muy fuerte tite lo sabe Y a
eso es a lo que más le temen por eso lo
que el entrenador de Brasil quiere es
que su equipo pueda marcar lo más pronto
posible en este partido para allá
digamos estar cómodos y de esta manera
pues hacerse con el control de la pelota
pero Croacia sabe muy bien y los hijos
la condalich el entrenador croata que la
idea es en el momento en que Brasil
pierda la pelota Ahí es donde Croacia
debe aprovechar esos momentos vamos
ahora del segundo duelo de esta jornada
Países Bajos contra Argentina otro
latinoamericano
Así es pues es un gran Duelo un duelo
con muchísima historia lo hemos venido
diciendo todos estos días pero sobre
todo pues la posibilidad de revancha
para los Países Bajos de poder ganar
finalmente a Argentina en esta instancia
cuando no pudieron hacerlo en 2014 en
ese momento fue el Arquero de Romero en
la que se hizo como en el gran en el
gran héroe en esa tanda de penales pero
ahora bueno las cosas han cambiado Esta
es otra Argentina por supuesto está
Lionel Messi habrá una marca importante
sobre él pero bueno los argentinos han
trabajado sobre este partido con
muchísima dedicación han tenido tiempo
de descanso ayer estuvimos en el
entrenamiento de ellos en la universidad
de Qatar donde se vio un ambiente muy
agradable de muchos abrazos de muchas
risas mucha tranquilidad y bueno de
todas maneras Leonel scaloni que sabe
muy bien que se va a enfrentar a un
equipo complicado un equipo que sabe
defender un equipo que sabe atacar todos
sus jugadores saben son muy buenos en
esto pero también pues él dijo que
espera que el partido no tenga que
llegar ya a la tanda de digamos un poco
como el acojo de todo esto porque él
dijo que sería mediocre de su parte
pensar el partido en esto así que este
es el encuentro que tendríamos y veremos
si finalmente los latinoamericanos
siguen a la siguiente ronda esa es un
poco la apuesta que han hecho los
latinoamericanos Para volver a ganar una
copa del mundo cosa que no ocurre desde